all over santiago long lines lead up to
new mobile vaccination centers to speed
up inoculations especially for people
under 30 who are now eligible but the
motivation for many of those getting
their jabs is not just fear of infection
health is important but i also want to
get the mobile path because they say it
will let us work and move around freely
despite the pandemic
the mobile pass or green passport was
implemented this week to allow people
who've been fully vaccinated to skip
many of the restrictions that apply to
everyone else they include going out
whenever you want and traveling to other
regions without a police permit which
might explain why santiago's bus
terminal is packed
in poland they're raffling cars to
reward those who are fully vaccinated
here in chile it's this mobility pass
that's the incentive but the problem is
that the sinovac chinese vaccine which
is what's most used in this country is
turning out not to be the silver bullet
that many had hoped
as in israel more than 50 percent of
chileans have been fully inoculated but
unlike in israel infections here
continue escalating up sixty percent in
the last two weeks here in the capital
the difference say epidemiologists is
the type of vaccine that's being used in
each country
vaccine is not very effective in
eliminating the circulation of the virus
it reduces symptomatic contagion by 50
to 67 percent as opposed to for example
the fisa vaccine that has around 95
percent efficacy in preventing contagion
the sinovac vaccine is extremely
effective in preventing serious cases of
coronavirus which in turn saves lives
there's also consensus that any vaccine
is better than none
and the chilean government is the only
one in latin america that's been able to
acquire enough to inoculate the entire
population but allowing people to move
around more freely with the virus still
circulating out of control is premature
says the doctor's guild
the government must make a really
scientific and technical analysis of the
measures they're implementing right now
and knowing that most of us are
vaccinated with sinovac well
we must deal with all the other measures
and not a green passport
that means better social distancing in
public transport using proper face masks
and waiting until almost everyone is
vaccinated before testing the waters for
greater social mobility
lucia newman al jazeera santiago